in Beijing people resort to Extreme
Measures to escape the fire that
engulfed A Private Hospital some climbed
out of the windows using bed sheets as
ropes others balanced on air
conditioning units clinging to the sides
of the building and those who were able
left onto nearby rooftops as the Flames
got dangerously close
[Music]
a fire broke out in the East building of
the inpatient Department of Beijing
changfong Hospital causing significant
casualties and we feel deep remorse and
guilt
most of the victims were elderly
patients the average age was 71. this is
the worst fire in Beijing in decades
hospitals say they are treating dozens
of people for Burns and smoke inhalation
with some in a critical condition police
are investigating the cause of The Blaze
according to a preliminary investigation
the fire was caused by Sparks generated
during the renovation of the inpatient
Department the Sparks ignited
combustible paint at the site
authorities say those responsible will
be held accountable
after investigation 12 people including
the director deputy director and head of
the general affairs Department of
Beijing changfong Hospital the person in
charge of the construction company the
onsai construction Personnel are
suspected of major responsibility
accidents
the suspects have been detained for
questioning while police investigate how
a place that is meant to provide care
for the sick and elderly became so
dangerously unsafe Jessica Washington Al
Jazeera Beijing